de tout temps les changements
climatiques ont perturbé les récoltes et
entraîné des réactions en chaîne plus ou
moins graves notre époque ne fait pas
exception à cette règle et cette année
est particulièrement compliquée pour les
producteurs de blé dur qui sert
notamment de matières premières à la
production de semoule ou de pâte dans
cette exploitation du sud de la région
parisienne
les mauvaises conditions climatiques ont
altéré la qualité des céréales récoltées
les comblant comme les blés temps et
avant même que le blanc ou double et en
saas par normal
j'aimerais 2
un transparent d'appeler un orage de
joueurs qui aiment le blé par terre son
mythe à dîner c'est dire que le gars il
est plus transparent il est devenu blanc
à l'intérieur donc
et puis il a un peu de mal a dit il et
où m c'est un biais qui s'est cassé la
figure qu'elle est tombée de finalement
depuis le 12 juin et à partir du moment
où il tombe par terre il se nourrit plus
et ça fait du tout du tout petit grain
au niveau national ces changements
climatiques inquiètent les
professionnels du secteur des pâtes et
de la semoule qui ont tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé le dérèglement climatique
mettent en danger le marché des pâtes
alimentaires
la saison pluvieuse en europe et la
sécheresse au canada premier producteur
mondial a déjà engendré une augmentation
des prix de près de 30% depuis juillet
et cela pourrait s'aggraver quand
l'ampleur des pertes de production sera
connu les professionnels français
veulent aujourd'hui que les
distributeurs amortissent les pertes il
va être urgent pour nous d'être capables
de répercuter cette hausse des prix du
blé dur auprès des prix de vente du
consommateur et nous sommes en
pourparlers avec la grande distribution
pour voir comment gérer cette crise pour
l'heure aucun chiffre n'a été avancé sur
l'augmentation du prix des pâtes la
tonne de blé dur coûte aujourd'hui 335
euros contre 270 euros le 7 juillet en
2007 le prix du blé dur et est monté à
400 euros en novembre avec même un pic à
520 euros en février 2008 et en juillet
le prix des pâtes avait augmenté de 20,9
pour cent environ c'est une dépense
supplémentaire sur des produits qui sont
certes bon marché mais qui tombe mal
alors que la crise du coc vite 19 a
serré la bourse de plus d'un ménage en
france